[Music]
on this tuesday night morning
and moving forward indigenous
communities grieve long-standing loss
and continue the search for children who
died in residential schools
canada needs to prepare to not get
triggered
but to focus on the end goal
of true truth and reconciliation
as the country reckons with its colonial
past and the men who built the country
mixing doses i'm happy to have a
cocktail
of vaccines new federal guidance green
lights switching vaccines for the second
dose
plus a canadian air force captain wins
her long battle with the military
and the once hidden history of the black
wall street massacre
now making headlines a survivor's story
100 years later
global national with donna friesen
good evening and thanks for joining us
we begin with the next steps in the
search for
all the unmarked graves of indigenous
children in this country
in saskatchewan where the last
residential school in this country
closed in 1997 there is a renewed push
to uncover the truth
[Music]
a ceremony was held today to reflect on
the trauma and honor what's believed to
be the remains of 215 children found
in unmarked graves at the former
kamloops indian residential school
the pain persists there were other
prayers and vigils today it's not that
no one knew thousands of indigenous
children died in residential schools run
by churches it's that
the people in charge didn't care today
former senator murray sinclair who
chaired the truth and reconciliation
commission
six years ago spoke out about the
multitude of stories he's been hearing
now
from survivors since the revelation of
what
was discovered at kamloops has come to
light
i have been inundated with phone calls
from survivors
by the dozens if not hundreds now
they've called me often just to cry
just to tell us
i told you so i told you that this had
happened
we know that there were probably
lots of sites similar to kamloops that
are going to come to
light in the future and
we need to begin to prepare ourselves
for that
indigenous leaders and elders have
quietly worked away on this
for years in our top story tonight ross
lord has the story
of a saskatchewan first nation using
ground penetrating radar
to found that find the truth about their
lost children
on the outskirts of regina people gather
at a cemetery where 36
indigenous children from the former
regina indian industrial school
are believed to have been buried based
on findings from a search
three years ago that forgiveness to me
is very important
because i'm a survivor i learned to
forgive the people who have done me
wrong
at another saskatchewan first nation
cowassis a similar search starts next
week
at this communal graveyard some graves
are marked
many are not as children most of the
people buried here
boarded at the maryvale residential
school every
residential grave site in this country
has these oral stories kamloops
is just one like other first nations
kaosis will rely on ground
penetrating radar to help identify
remains we don't know what we're going
to find
ground radar sends radio waves into the
earth through an antenna
the transmitted energy is reflected back
from buried objects
the antenna receives reflected waves
which are amplified
and displayed as different colors it's
not going to give you
a black and white answer but it's going
to pinpoint to the right direction
most of the time it's not an exact
survey confirming the gruesome truth
about what's underground
could mean excavating the earth and
bringing remains to the surface
for forensic examinations canada needs
to prepare
to not get triggered but to focus
on the end goal of true truth and
reconciliation
as we do these he hopes after
identifying and recognizing all remains
his first nation can install a monument
telling the story
of what happened there ross lord global
news
in kamloops the next steps will take
time the tekemloops elders and people
are in charge of the process there and
while the focus
is on the graves of children of the past
many indigenous children alive today
are still not getting the care they
deserve nithyud garcia is in kamloops
for us tonight neetu what are you
hearing from the people there
well donna we've heard community leaders
and members plan to meet today
amid growing calls for answers about
that search that led to this discovery
the findings and what happens next but
we won't get those answers today because
the focus we're told
is on healing and grieving and honoring
the traditional methods
of doing so this comes five days after
they announced the discovery of the
remains of
hundreds of children in unmarked burial
sites where the kamloops indian
residential school in bc was located
but many say five days just isn't enough
time for them to process
being re-traumatized and how is the
wider community in kamloops reacting
well donna we've been speaking to
members living here on the unseated and
traditional territories of the tekken
loops to schweppem nation
and many of them are in shock five days
after learning about that discovery and
they say
that they want to see other residential
schools across this country doing
similar searches and they believe that
this discovery
could lead to a national moment of
reckoning
across the country especially with the
international attention
that this has gotten like we've seen
across canada more
symbols of the stories that can never be
told continue to be erected here
these children's shirts we saw today
near the former residential school are a
painfully vivid reminder
of the young lives that have been lost
and we spoke to a member of the
chawepnik nation
whose relatives attended that school and
she says
it did re-traumatize her family what are
the next steps what can we do as a
nation what
needs to occur even after
like the drumming ceremonies here
indigenous people
they're feeling like they need more
more healing process to occur it's
horrible and it happened
and we just can't let it happen again so
i don't know what they're doing with
that building or that site but
this has to bring awareness to everyone
that our indigenous culture they have
been mistreated and it's time to
time to stand up for them a bit and show
them that we support them
so donna the bottom line here is that it
is going to be a slow
process towards getting more answers
about this discovery
and how it was discovered this as many
are hoping it will be a catalyst for
true understanding
of the effects of multiple generations
of
severed family ties and cultural
linkages that continue to be
experienced by young people in care
today
donna all right nithya garcia in
kamloops tonight thanks schools should
be places of learning not dying they
shouldn't have cemeteries and yet
residential schools across this country
did
the most common cause of death was
disease in about a third of the deaths
the schools in the government
didn't even document the name of the
child it's hard to imagine anything so
racist
and callous yet it is a recent part of
our past
and as eric sorenson reports there is
still much
learning to do about how this country
was built
it was an understated statue canada's
first prime minister on a park bench in
the cradle of confederation
charlottetown now it's gone removed by
workers after a city council vote
in its place dozens of children's shoes
signifying the disturbing discovery of
bodies
buried at the residential school in
kamloops bc
mcdonald was a proponent of residential
schools and indigenous leaders say his
role as a nation builder cannot ignore
that fact
the history has taught a side of story
which makes it makes it look good
there's another side of the story which
isn't very
very well received history is a
one-sided
snapshot of the way things work
the removal symbolizes the reckoning
that is forcing canadians to come to
terms with the figures who built the
country
but also entrenched policies that abused
and damaged first nations
ryerson university named for edgerton
ryerson who helped design the
residential school system
is under pressure to change the school
name and to remove his statue
the school is already changing the name
of publications like the ryersonian
the university of british columbia is
reviewing an honorary degree given to
catholic bishop john fergus o'grady
who was the principal at the kamloops
residential school
stripping degrees or taking down statues
may be right but it's not enough
says this indigenous studies professor
at ubc those things may be worth doing
and they may be important to do
but the more important thing is to
really try to understand what made those
things reasonable in the first place
getting canadians to truly understand is
a challenge
bc's premier called the discovery of
bodies in kamloops unimaginable
but many including this indigenous mla
says it's not
for indigenous people this story is not
shocking
nor is it unimaginable
this is the trauma our families have
carried for generations
a professor at ryerson says canadians
must educate themselves about the
current and historic treatment of
indigenous people
canadians are part of the problem
and they need to be intentional about
how not to be part of the problem
and also to advocate the proper
authorities
to take up their responsibilities to end
it
and say indigenous leaders part of
reconciliation must hold honored figures
like john a macdonald to account
because how indigenous people were
treated must be central to the story of
this country
eric sorensen global news toronto
there is some support for survivors a
24-hour crisis line is available for
anyone experiencing pain or distress
as a result of their residential school
experience you can call toll-free and
speak in confidence the number is
1-866-925
mixing it up coming up the options for
your second dose
the cfl team in edmonton which was under
pressure to change its old name
the eskimos has announced its new name
when our heads are down you know it's on
the team is now the edmonton elks it
hopes to start the 2021 football season
in august
there's been much debate about adding
the s to elks the team says it consulted
linguistic
experts and decided elks is acceptable
as the plural form of
elk there is new clarity tonight for
canadians who got their first dose of
astrazeneca and are wondering what will
happen
with their second the national advisory
committee on immunization has given the
provinces the green light to mix and
match vaccines
they say if you got astrazeneca it is
now safe to switch to an mrna vaccine
for your second shot alberta manitoba
saskatchewan quebec
and pei have adopted the mix and match
approach other provinces are expected to
follow suit
abigail beeman reports on the evidence
behind the decision
and what it means for canada's rollout
all of my other gen
xers did that week i think everybody i
know in that 40-something age bracket
anne-marie joyce and her husband are in
that 40-plus age group that got
astrazeneca as soon as they could
and then faced mixed messages when the
national advisory committee on
immunization
stressed mrna vaccines were preferred
now nasty says she's clear to choose her
second dose
and get an mrna vaccine i'm happy to
have a cocktail
of vaccines i'm 100 percent confident
and happy to take a mrna vaccine as my
second dose
nasi's discretionary recommendation
cited the rare but serious blood clots
linked to astrazeneca
as well as emerging if limited studies
on mixing doses
data from the united kingdom from spain
and also from real world experience in
france and germany who are already doing
this
demonstrating that yeah it looks like it
is
a safe thing to do and not only that it
actually provides a pretty significant
and robust immune response
it's now up to provinces to implement
several have said they will
it's the choice of of the person to
decide if she they want to get the
second dose by
from estras if you do choose an mrna
vaccine after astrazeneca
be prepared for a chance of rougher side
effects post
jab headaches fatigue feeling generally
ill
they are temporary and without
complications the committee also
clarified advice around
mixing mrna vaccines pfizer and moderna
try and find the same vaccine same mri
vaccine but if you can't for some reason
then they consider them interchangeable
no one from nasty was
at tuesday's briefing the chair tells
global news it asked the public health
agency of canada to take over
communication saying the situation was
becoming quote
unsustainable dr carolyn quashtan also
told global news her term is up in
nine days and she'll be replaced by vice
chair
dr shelley deeks abigail beeman global
news
ottawa the number of canadians who are
fully vaccinated is expected to rise
faster over the coming weeks as of
tonight about 57 percent of canadians
have had at least one dose
and 5.6 percent have been fully
vaccinated
still ahead a new review finds old
problems in canada's military
are still rampant
a 15-year battle between canadian air
force veteran kimberly fawcett and the
military
is over fawcett will be compensated for
injuries she suffered while on duty
including disability benefits to cover
her treatment
and prosthetics in 2006 fawcett was hit
by a truck after getting out of her
vehicle that had spun out on the ice
she was carrying her son at the time he
was killed
it happened as she was heading to the
canadian forces base kingston and
preparing to be deployed to afghanistan
a military investigation initially ruled
she was off duty at the time
today the veterans review and appeal
board said the tragic chain of events
was
directly due to military orders
a new independent report into the
canadian military's justice system
tabled in parliament today reveals
sexual misconduct is just as rampant and
destructive now
as it was in 2015. that's when a
landmark federal report first documented
the extent of the problem
mercedes stephenson on the
recommendations in today's report
and the timeline for implementing them
this is the most comprehensive
independent review of the military
justice system
since the 1990s in the six years that
justin trudeau's
self-styled feminist government has been
in power things have not improved for
victims of sexual misconduct in the
military
former supreme court justice morris
fish's scathing review of the military
justice system
comes in the midst of a sexual
misconduct firestorm for the forces
the third such controversy in 30 years
the process is
i think very broken victims of sexual
misconduct have been failed by
successive governments
and they say they have little to no
confidence in the military
police and the military justice system i
don't think that they have enough
resources and personnel
qualified at the level for this type of
investigation
the landmark report is over 400 pages
long
with 107 recommendations for a
significant overhaul
of the military justice system the most
striking recommendation
for the civilian justice system to step
in and take over
investigating and trying sexual offenses
from the military
until the forces introduced reforms and
protections for victims
that was supposed to happen two years
ago but has never been implemented
we have a broken military law system
fish did not
recommend removing sexual offenses from
the military justice system
as many victims rights groups and
experts have
i don't think it's gone as far as i
would like it to be
for the sake of those victims the
military's top judge
is promising a better future military
justice
actors have been very reluctant to
change as the current
judge advocate general i fully embrace
the
recommendations made by justice fish the
liberal government says they're
committed to accepting fish's
recommendations
in principle but would not provide
specifics on a timeline for the changes
a critical piece of the puzzle victims
say they continue to hope for change
but will believe it when they see it
mercedes stevenson global news
ottawa
next a massacre of hundreds of black
americans you likely
have never heard about
one hundred years ago on this day there
was horror going on
in tulsa oklahoma a white mob burned
down one of the wealthiest black
communities in the country destroying
homes and businesses
killing hundreds of people bodies were
buried in unmarked graves
it was a massacre driven by racism and
the story of what happened in tulsa has
largely been forgotten or
erased hell was unleashed
literal hell was unleashed through the
night
and in the morning the mob terrorized
green with torches and guns
shooting at will as soon as it happened
there was a clear effort to erase it
from our memory
today u.s president joe biden visited
tulsa as part of commemorations there
he is the first president to do so
jackson proskow reports on today's
events in a warning some images in his
story
are disturbing the burning of black wall
street lasted
two days in 1921 a white mob
torched the prosperous black community
of greenwood
murdering dozens of residents robbing
them of their lives and livelihoods
thousands of black tulsans were arrested
and held for weeks
i described the massacre as the worst
single
incident of racial violence in american
history for the past 45 years historian
scott ellsworth has worked to expose the
tulsa race massacre
an atrocity wiped from the history books
and rarely spoken about
even by survivors the question is why
haven't i heard of this before
and the reason was that for a long time
people made sure that you weren't
going to hear about it no one has ever
been held accountable
the death toll of 300 is still just an
estimate
i'm a survivor of the tulsa race
massacre
survivors like 107 year old viola
fletcher have begun to tell their
stories
as they plead for a formal reckoning i
hear the screams
i have lived through the massacre every
day
a country may forget this history but i
cannot
these charred pennies collected by a
five-year-old survivor named george
monroe
are a relic of the destruction the mob
brought and a reminder of the wealth
that was destroyed
100 years later greenwood is still a
shadow of what it once was
a new generation of entrepreneurs is
pushing for reparations
and restoration if the land
was deeded back to people that had
some tie i think that would be
the the easiest way to start to repair
the atrocities of the past the recent
discovery of mass graves
shows there's still so much to account
for dozens of suspected victims were
buried anonymously at
sites across tulsa these are murder
victims these are these are massacre
victims right here
it's unlikely that all will be
identified but they will for the first
time
be acknowledged as tulsa seeks to heal
and as americans learn about their own
hidden history
jackson prosco global news washington
and that is global national for this
tuesday i'm donna friesen
across canada today people stood silent
in tribute to the indigenous children
who are believed to have been buried in
unmarked graves
at the former kamloops indian
residential school in british columbia
and at 2 15 local time the bells of the
hillhurst united church in calgary rang
215 times
once for every child thanks for watching
take care of yourselves
bye